[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce lundi à 16
janvier 2017
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines active son plan divers pour
lutter contre le froid et la neige les
saleuses étaient de sortie ce week-end
notamment pour assurer la sécurité des
piétons et des automobilistes
quel bilan touristique pour le château
de versailles entre sécurité exposition
phare l'atout numéro 1 du département
des yvelines a connu une année 2016
contrastée mais les ambitions restent
élevés pour la nouvelle année
enfin vous verrez que la solidarité et
le bénévolat ne sont pas réservées
uniquement aux anciens des jeunes
s'engagent aussi et notamment au sein du
secours populaire français local non au
début de ce journal sur ces images de
neige et divers alors qu'une vague de
froid arrive sur la france et la région
ile de france cette semaine à saint
quentin en yvelines les services de
l'agglomération sont entrés en action
dès ce week-end avec les quelques
flocons à qui sont tombées sur le
territoire
l'objectif sur des sorties lors
d'épisodes neigeux c'est de traiter au
plus près de l'événement donc d'attendre
que d'épisodes soit déjà un petit peu
significatif avec de la neige qui tient
au sol alors en fait l'action du sel
permet de diminuer la température de
solidification de l'eau donc ça permet
d'éviter la formation de plaques de
glace lorsque la température descend en
dessous de zéro pendant la nuit et ça
permet effectivement d'accélérer aussi
la fonte de la neige
lors du passage des véhicules sachez
d'ailleurs que l'agglomération met en
place un service dallaire par sms
jusqu'au 31 mars prochain celui-ci vous
permet de connaître les différentes
opérations de salage et de déneigement
plus de précisions sur www.sfr.fr à la
verrière la maire communiste nelly duthu
présenté il ya quelques jours ses
premiers voeux à la population et aux
différents services de la commune dans
la salle de spectacle du scarabée
elle est revenue
notamment sur les difficultés autour du
projet de la zac est gardée cannes un
projet qui prévoit la construction de
1800 logements et d'un pôle d'activités
économiques de 80 mille mètres carrés
lancée en 2013 par la communauté
d'agglomération et la ville
le projet est aujourd'hui à l'arrêt les
deux parties s'opposent sur son ampleur
écoutez à ce propos et nelly duthu au
micro de camille l'envers on a le maire
d'elancourt qui bloque vraiment le
projet en apportant le soutien de
monsieur lange et le scan madame rosetti
le soutien de me surveiller le soutien
de la ministre du logement
enfin on a tous les soutiens possibles
et viable tout le monde nous dit que le
projet est viable que le territoire on a
besoin pour son expansion que nous la
ville on en a besoin pour respirer
politique toujours mais à droite cette
fois ci le député yvelinois henri guaino
veut aller jusqu'au bout déclaration ce
matin en référence à sa candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle alors que la
situation se tend depuis plusieurs jours
avec son party les républicains un parti
qui a suspendu son investiture aux
élections législatives dans la troisième
circonscription des yvelines henri
guaino est un farouche opposant à
françois fillon le vainqueur de la
primaire de la droite et du centre et de
son programme et qu'il juge je cite
contraires à ces engagements
peur des attentats état d'urgence le
secteur touristique à paris et de sa
région sont en proie depuis des mois des
difficultés chroniques pour faire
revenir les touristes du monde entier
leur nombre a baissé d'ailleurs de 6% à
paris en 2016 hôtels musées et monuments
sont ainsi les plus touchés par la
tendance c'est le cas par exemple dans
les yvelines du château de versailles et
qui a connu cette année des mouvements
contrastés les précisions d'alice
deschamps et d'haussmann avant de rld et
l'heure est au bilan pour le château de
versailles l'année 2016 a été difficile
avec une baisse du tourisme étranger de
6% mais les fêtes de fin d'année ont été
plutôt bonnes pour le château avec un
taux de fréquentation d'environ 10% en
est à 6 millions 700 mille visiteurs ce
qui est tout de même déjà un très beau
chiffre par rapport à 7 millions et demi
l'année dernière
et ses six millions 7 se décompose en 4
millions de visiteurs au château par
rapport aux 4 millions et demi à peu
près l'année précédente
un million trois cent mille pour les
trianon et les jardins et 1 million 400
mille pour les spectacles ce qui veut
dire aussi que versailles a cette
particularité d'être multiculturelle
d'offrir une offre de programmation très
diversifiée et donc les spectacles ont
permis de compenser aussi un peu dans
une période plus morose et plus
difficile avec des publics plus locaux
plus franciliens pour pallier à cette
baisse le château a mis en place
plusieurs stratégies la première attirer
les touristes français grâce à des
partenariats avec des offices de
tourisme comme celle de paris mais aussi
créer un lien de proximité avec les
touristes étrangers qui représentent 60
% de la fréquentation annuelle
nous nous tournons vers nos visiteurs
traditionnels qu'il s'agisse des états
unis mais c'est aussi une politique
d'exposition ambitieuse vers l'ex vers
l'étranger ou le château sorte de ses
murs habituel pour aller montrer une
grande partie de ses collections pas
toujours visible pour tous nous pour
tous nos visiteurs habituellement c'est
le cas au japon en ce moment avec une
exposition sur marie antoinette qui se
déroule jusqu en mars qui a déjà
accueilli à tokyo deux cent mille
visiteurs à la fin d'année et puis une
autre exposition en australie à canberra
qui a démarré il ya peu près de même
trois semaines qui marchent également
très très bien et qui vise à démontrer
que le musée ne se fige pas non plus
dans ces lieux la stratégie marketing de
2017 est simple continuer les
expositions à l'étranger pour développer
la notoriété du château de versailles
et pour faire revenir les touristes en
ile de france la région présidée par
valérie pécresse se montre active
notamment sur le plan sécuritaire
l'ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy
annoncé récemment lors d'un déplacement
à plaisir un investissement important
pour l'installation de vidéosurveillance
dans l'ensemble des gares routières de
la région une nouvelle qui concerne donc
saint quentin en yvelines
la vidéoprotection devrait être aussi
augmenté dans les bus pour équiper 60%
des véhicules d'ici à la fin de l'année
on écoute valérie pécresse au micro de
michael et demi d'euros la sécurité au
monde couronne s'est très
pourtant parce que malheureusement et
bien on a renforcé le dispositif de
sécurité à paris et en petite couronne
et je ne voulais pas que la grande
couronne soit l'angle mort de nous
de sécurité c'est pour ça avec bruno
le ministre de l'intérieur nous allons
lancer très vite la sécurisation du 70
gares routières notamment toutes celles
de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis la vidéo protection dans tous
les bus de grande couronne
comme ces cartes ont la ratp elle les
automobilistes et les motards sont
également dans l'actualité ce lundi avec
la mise en place désormais obligatoire à
paris est des vignettes et critères sur
les pare-brise des véhicules ces
vignettes indiquent les différents
niveaux de pollution et attention si
vous ne l'avez pas pour circuler dans la
capitale durant la semaine vous risquez
une amende de 45 euros pour l'obtenir
rendez vous sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de vos écrans 3 w pour un certificat
tirer erp en gouv.fr si vous étiez du
côté de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines jeudi dernier vous avez
sûrement croisé la police qui menaient
une opération de prévention destinée
surtout aux piétons mois après
différents accidents survenus ces
derniers jours cette action avait pour
objectif de sensibiliser au danger
lorsque l'on traverse en respecter le
code de la route camille lambert pour
les précisions traverser au bonhomme
rouge quand il n'y a pas de voitures la
tentation est grande mais le danger
toujours présent c'est ce qu'a souhaité
rappeler la police lors d'une opération
de prévention jeudi 12 janvier
une action menée suite aux différents
accidents survenus récemment deux
accidents très préoccupant a
en fin d'année pour une personne se
trouvant sur un passage piétons passant
oger a été renversé par un véhicule qui
passait lui aussi au vert mais
débouchant d'une autre artère est très
récemment la semaine passée un jeune
garçon de 14 ans qui traverse en venant
de la gare pour prendre un bus a
traversé la chaussée au rouge piétons et
bien sûr s'est fait renverser par
malheureusement deux véhicules
antérieurs 107 chauffeur l'an dernier
c'est ce piéton ont perdu la vie dans le
département une augmentation de 50% par
rapport à 2015 une dizaine de policiers
nationaux et municipaux ont donc stoppé
les imprudents aux abords de l'avenue du
centre de montigny le bretonneux
aujourd'hui les conditions météo ne sont
pas bonnes les gens sont souvent
habillés en sombre emmitouflés dans des
capuches et sous des parapluies ce qui
diminue fortement leur champ de
visibilité leur perception des dangers
de la route
le but de l'opération aujourd'hui n'est
pas de sanctionner mais de sensibiliser
les piétons aux risques qu'ils prennent
en traversant la chaussée sans respecter
la sinisation sont respectées le
marquage au sol
je pensais avoir le temps de passer
avant que avant que le pétrole
deviennent rouges
donc j'ai mal jugé des agents en civil
ont également relevé les infractions des
véhicules un refus de priorité à un
piéton est sanctionné par un retrait de
quatre points sur le permis de conduire
et 135 euros d'amendé
dans le reste de l'actualité locale
secours populaire des yvelines fêtera
cette année ses 50 ans l'association
organisé ce week-end sa cérémonie des
voeux attrape un événement durant lequel
un hommage a été rendu à l'ensemble des
bénévoles l'engagement en faveur des
plus démunis ne faiblit pas et semble
même attirer les plus jeunes
reportage lors languit et nicolas landry
pour lille ou 15 ans pas question de
consacrer tout son temps à ses copines
ou à leur famille
l'adolescente est bénévole au secours
populaire depuis trois ans je suis très
fier de faire ça et ça m'apporte du
bonheur ça me fait plaisir en fait de
donner de mon temps et mon énergie
j'ai déjà aidé bon plusieurs collectes
alimentaires et puis là j'ai organisé
une collecte de jouets dans mon essai il
n'y a donc pas d'âge pour donner de son
temps aux autres
le secours populaire souhaite que chaque
bénévole trouve son intérêt dans les
différentes actions qu'ils proposent
entre les collectes de jouets de
vêtements l'émission père noël ou encore
l'accompagnement des petits en vacances
moi ma tâche moi c'est faire les
accompagnements des enfants dans les
familles d'accueil
je fais ça de gare en gare gare
parisienne une gare de province et
ensuite trois semaines après je vais
aller rechercher
on l'a ramené à leur part ont fait
beaucoup de choses et c'est beaucoup de
choses diversifié c'est surtout ce qui
est intéressant c'est parce que on fait
pour toujours la même chose le secours
populaire des yvelines et compte ainsi
1800 bénévoles répartis dans 25
structures pour seulement quatre
salariés une petite armée de bonne
volonté
c'est consacrer du temps aux autres me
dire que je me lève le matin et que ça
sert à quelque chose
le secours populaire des yvelines compte
sur cette année anniversaire pour
recueillir des idées fraîches auprès de
ses bénévoles
plusieurs congrès seront organisées tout
au long de l'année afin de renouveler la
gouvernance de l'association et
réfléchir à l'avenir et y est des love
me do vous connaissez sûrement ses
titres incontournables des beats et bien
ils ont repris vie sur scène ce week-end
grâce au groupe the bootleg beatles ils
ont incarné le combo mythique sur les
planches du cirano de versailles
vendredi dernier retour sur ce concert
en images avec camille lambert
m
john paul ringo et djordje les fab fort
au complet était au cirano de versailles
de vendredi 13 janvier
ou plutôt leurs sosies de bootleg
beatles le groupe de reprises à rejouer
le lay mythique de 1964 premier concert
de peter en france dans cette même salle
[Musique]
cards off montsûrs study of sa blonde et
moi pour étudier des vidéos est
évidemment mémoriser la manière dont ils
se conduisaient sur scène la façon de
tenir leurs instruments la façon aussi
de bouger leur tête de parler à leur
public
le plus important c'est ensuite de
pratiquer soit dans des mois pour un
résultat parfait tract considéré comme
le meilleur trip 2 bennes du combo
anglais de bootleg little a tourné dans
le monde entier depuis sa création en
1978 ce concert anniversaire était leur
premier en région parisienne le public
leur a réservé un accueil chaleureux
the beatles extraordinaire ils ont
réussi à faire lever tout le monde à
faire danser tout le monde dans le
tyranneau donc exceptionnel avec cette
ambiance là franchement sa première fois
qu'on a le feu comme ça au cirano chance
je pense qu'ils étaient très
intelligents dans l'écriture de leurs
chansons il semblait par là une très
large audience les écrivais constamment
de bonnes chansons c'est ça qui a cédé
beatles les beatles de twist and shout
à ticket to ride la hit machine a
conquis les spectateurs versaillais de
bouclettes beatles reviendra en juin
avec une tournée française pour les 50
ans de l'album
certes on peut mais
fin de ce 7 8 le journal rendez vous
demain mardi aux horaires habituels pour
une nouvelle édition d'ici là tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver en replay
sur notre site internet tv fil 78 points
com ou sur l'application aux tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]